hi reject nation I'm Greg Alva John so
both of our hairs are slicked back
because it's much easier to get
camera-ready at a last minutes notice
when you didn't know goosebumps -
trailer was dropping but here we are
people goosebumps - haunted Halloween
full disclosure I have seen goosebumps
John has it no let's do it again
John has seen goosebumps I haven't seen
goosebumps that's right oh man you
missed out I've heard it was a
delightful surprise but hey John would
you mind if we did a page in the day
shout-out super quick before we add all
this if we must I'm just kidding I want
to give a patron the day shout out to
Natalie Doran today Natalie Doran I
understand you just had your first trip
to America all the way from Ireland saw
that you went to Florida looks like you
had a hell of a time got drunk plenty of
times got bikini-ready good for you
darling
you look great and also I thought it
would just be appropriate to give you a
shout out here because you give John and
I both sexy goosebumps especially here
for the nipple chills
that's all you darlin and of course
you're from Ireland once right Emerald
Isle we're down to Disney World you seem
like somebody who might end up in a
goosebumps story so I feel like this is
this is appropriate amen to that sister
I think you'd be the protagonist anyway
let's watch this
uno dos tres
JK Rowling
[Music]
last time good people like me haven't
seen it looks like the rampage
from it think so
this place is giving out candy feels
like it meets Jumanji welcome to the
jungle
[Music]
haunted Halloween
[Music]
did you miss me
[Music]
you discovered a whopping topping dummy
and you didn't tell me
okay well he seemed like a really nice
guy at the start
[Music]
super-tiny in cuba can't possibly do
maybe just commie bears of course that
was an oddly-shaped trailer so from my
understanding the first goosebumps is
Jumanji s and then this one the
aesthetic was reminding me of the first
20 minutes of Jumanji welcome to the
jungle yeah then you even got the blonde
girl from Jumanji welcome to the jungle
in here yeah then you also get some of
the Apes yeah yeah and you got the kid
from it but it's also got some of the it
vibes in the house and especially when
you hear the dummy's voice again yeah
did you miss me then you also got the
black kid Khalil Harris who's gonna be
in Castle Rock which is a Stephen King
show we take you see you came I guess
that makes sense because at least the
Jumanji movie and a lot of the
Goosebumps books are things of the 90s
you know literally accessible to the
youth for how kind of scary they can be
yeah yeah and I also think that
goosebumps too could actually kind of
get away with not bringing back the same
cast members oh yeah because like it do
exactly in a different scenario it still
feels like a semi continuation at the
same time I am kind of curious though as
to is that a story choice or was this
just a studio greenlit sequel because
they don't have any of the original
writers or the original director and
none of the original cast yeah blank
slate is it just one of those like we
just wanted a sequel so we just got to
do it anyway and no one wants to return
for it to they don't have an idea yeah
so we should just do one anyway you know
yeah I mean the only thing I'm kind of
taken aback by maybe is I just really
was dazzled by Jack Black as RL Stein
and that seemed like an appropriate
through-line
especially because Jack Black also
voiced slappy in the original movies so
now I'm like did they get a new voice
for that are they gonna surprise this
with some kind of joke yeah I know they
did move the release date of this away
from the house of the clock and its
walls so maybe this is cool to me too
though because this is coming out right
before Halloween just a couple weeks
before Halloween
conard Halloween and it's nice that kids
can have a movie to watch on Halloween
normally Halloween movies that are
driven around Halloween time or for
adults yeah it's cool that like families
can go out and actually have a movie to
watch at that time like there ought to
be more kid accessible horror not like
horror necessarily like dumbed down you
know to a child level but you know I
feel like people often reminisce about
the gateway horror stuff they had that
got them into that yeah that's the void
I think goosebumps could be really cool
at filling yeah I know the other one
came out around Halloween as well yeah
2015 yeah so I'm like this is a cool
franchise for kids to have right now
yeah well in this one I mean it looks
very Halloween and I love that aesthetic
in a horror movie because not every
horror movie is Halloween time yeah and
I love you know you got these different
like Halloween decorations coming to
life and stuff like that looks like it's
gonna really be steeped in all it looks
like a Disney original movie great of
them teetering on with goose bumps
because the first one teetered on that
too but there was enough actual peril to
kind of separate it but I'm always
afraid that Guzman's gonna fall into
that hole I mean the town and vibe of
this is definitely I mean especially the
effects of when they're all coming out
of this store looks very much like this
is like a Disney Channel original film
has that quality too because they have
the prominent bumper of Sony animation
or whatever so like the animation studio
rather than just like a regular CG team
is what they're kind of leading with
effects on that and the first one they
were at least whimsical enough in their
animation that I understand how the one
leads to the other but I don't know this
is kind of a funky shaped trailer cuz
you have like so much last time at the
beginning and then you own stuff and
then you kind of end on a note that
reminded me the first one cuz in the
first one you have like a ton of
monsters breaking out right I'm not sure
what do you expect in this but I like
the aesthetic I mean it looks fun it
looks fun and now you need a trailer
with some actual plot it's a little more
scene work but you know in the meantime
this looks like will people probably
expect it to be and are maybe
disappointed that Jack Black's not back
he was my problem alright guys well are
you still gonna watch goosebumps - with
or without Jack Black not like he
invented the franchise anyway but he did
kick off you know he is our L Stein
that's gonna be a cool thing to have him
in there anyway listen you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons are essentially broken these
days and you can check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions we got
weekly Q&A s music video coverage would
love to have you become a patron oject
today